let's keep this party rolling our next
comedian is the newest member of kill
tony put your hands together for hans
kim
hey what's up guys
uh my name is hans kim and i'm sexually
active
i love the ladies i don't think i could
ever [ __ ] a dude
i've never looked at a beautiful woman
i've been like wow is there a version of
her that's bigger and hairier and has
less kindness
i want to put that on my butthole
straight as [ __ ]
please believe me my dad doesn't
uh i think it's funny that tanner is a
white person's name
tanner then what
she'll be like hey this is my mexican
friend tanner
that's my black friend tanist
just a suffix joke
uh i'm not a racist i don't even see
race i only smell it
i was on an airplane and i saw a dude
reading a book in arabic which kind of
freaked me out but then i saw him fold
the corner of the page and put the book
away and i was like oh thank god he's
got future plans
i uh my favorite marvel movie is the
black panther movie
because it gave black children a hero
they could finally look up to
and not just someone like martha king jr
malcolm x or harriet tubman or thurgood
marshall or george washington carver
frederick douglass or w b dubois
booker t washington will smith cindy
samuel jackson lebron james obama oprah
muhammad ali
tupac piggy
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat
hooray
you did it blacks
where they gonna come out with our movie
the yellow panda
[Applause]
slow but steady he's gonna eat your
furniture
well i am asian or as i've known this
country i'm chinese
i'm from a province in china called
south korea
it's right next to the japan province
i love being asian because whenever
someone is racist to me i'm just like
what you hate respectful people who keep
to themselves
good luck finding an affordable car
most people who are racist don't even
know that they are like this guy came up
to me and he was like
i was like dude just because i look like
this doesn't mean i speak your ching
chong language
don't be racist and the post office is
right there
i
i get made fun of a lot by my asian
friends for not being asian enough
like dude you like to eat generous
chicken that's not asian at all
it generally says chicken isn't that
just a shitty americanized version of
something authentically asian
i was like yeah but so am i
my favorite movie is rush hour 3.
i love being an asian man but everyone
thinks asian women are beautiful which i
don't understand because how do you
think asian women are created
me [ __ ]
i'm a crucial part of the sexy process
please stop trying to skip me
if you have sex with me our children
will be very beautiful
half of them
the other half will be great engineers
and that's important too
i'm not a big fan of asian women sorry
lady
one over here too
uh sorry i don't like you guys that much
because uh asian women always act like
they're hotter than asian men but we
look exactly the same [ __ ]
could throw on a wig and be a seven
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they're always bragging that they could
[ __ ] white dudes dude i can [ __ ] white
dudes
we can all [ __ ] white dudes
it's not impressive
i am single i have yet to meet my soul
mate i'm beginning to think maybe it's
her fault she needs to get out more
she seems like a loser
i think i could do better
my friend's like dude need to learn how
to talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn how to
listen to hans
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
where the party relax
uh this one girl was like did you know
that my vagina can make a baby so my
vagina is actually a 3d printer
i was like actually your womb is a 3d
printer your vagina is the tray
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
it takes nine months to print
and the whole time is printing is
complaining
needless to say i did not see any trays
that night
but i do love the ladies i think it's a
good thing that they give birth i feel
like if men gave birth we'd be like bro
i better do so much protein and creatine
during my pregnancy
this baby's like 27 pounds ready bro
it's all about those gains in the first
trimester
check out his biceps on the ultrasound
i
i do love uh the ladies and stuff uh a
lot of ladies call me a premature
ejaculator which hurts my feelings
because premature to who
i came right at the perfect time when i
felt amazing
it takes maturity now to please yourself
uh but i uh i don't understand all the
sayings in english they say in prison
don't drop the soap it should be don't
pick up the soap
you can drop as much soap as you want
it's the bending over where they really
get you you know
even if you don't drop the soap you're
still gonna get raped you're just gonna
have really clean hands while it happens
who are these rapists like man i want to
get that kid but he never drops a soap
does he have a butthole we'll never know
rapists are go-getters they don't take
no for an answer
but uh i am single
i uh
i used to date this woman who was really
into yoga and choke sex and i was like
do you enjoy breathing or not
with your mind
it's good to be here in texas uh i am
also from the south i'm from south korea
yeah
there's only two things i like shooting
commies and k-pop
i love texas because i love rednecks
rednecks can survive in any wilderness
situation that you put them in except a
situation where everyone has equal
rights
you can live in a swamp with an
alligator why can't you live in a
cul-de-sac with a minority
all right that's my time thank you guys
very
[Applause]
but he keep digging much see me i love
him